whoa meg they're you
and you look amazing our favorite movies
could have turned out completely
different in an alternate universe some
on the other hand just dropped fun jokes
in favor of even funner ones we're
checking out 20 cutscenes from disney
and pixar's latest animated movies
starting with turning red my panda my
choice mom
number one do you know the pickup line
this is the answer to the official
turning red deleted scenes haven't been
released yet but one wholesome
canadian-esque joke didn't make the cut
and was instead replaced with some
science joke ugh are you a triangle
cause you were
[Music]
cute kidding it was also good and
slightly more relevant but we're still
sad over the loss of this one are you a
beaver cause damn
number two
spotted in the turning red documentary
embraced the panda was this short bit of
the little beans protesting and flopping
do you remember the asdf movies
everybody do the flop
there's much less power in the people
when they're lying on the floor i can't
just talk about myself i'm only part of
the amazing madrid
number three we want this to be a whole
spin-off movie isabella goes into the
woods to meet up with a dude named bobo
marquez she plans on running away with
this city slicker who has slicked
himself with animal urine and dressed
himself in a kitty cat costume to keep
the animals away isabella proceeds to
make out with bobo in front of her
sister and it's long and awkward you saw
nothing i wish i saw nothing we couldn't
make this stuff up if we tried guys what
we can't figure out is just why it got
cut it's obviously a
cinematic masterpiece
what is this dark magic what did you do
to her
number four turns out these magical
rooms actually have limits there was a
guinea pig named el bondigo that's all
you need to know about this deleted
scene just kidding mirabelle traveled
through antonio's room and fell through
the floor slash ground into luis's room
had we have gotten this scene we may
never have seen dancing donkeys in
surface pressure and that would have
been a tragedy eventually i'm gonna sing
you a song right here yeah that's right
number five have you ever tried to trick
a two-year-old into putting their toys
in the toy box as a game
yeah it doesn't work imagine trying that
with a teenager mirabelle gets stuck
doing chores with the non-magical dads
of the family who try to make them seem
like fun we got a peek into dolores room
before her magical power was finalized
peppa was indestructible still alive
[Music]
and we also got the summary of the fight
that happened between abuela and bruno
back when bruno was still called oscar
he was sensitive snap like a tweet
number six you can never go home
personally we're glad this scene was
replaced the ending originally had
mirabelle running away to the city after
her mom was injured abuela chases
mirabelle gets herself lost in a sea of
technological evolutions but then comes
across a mural of her husband
accompanied by the words to love it all
is to love entirely the rest of the
scene on the bench plays out similar to
how it did in the movie
none of this is your fault
i chose to leave this city number seven
while captivating this scene was lacking
intrigue
wow
that was hard to watch
the original opening of luca had a
mysterious boy sneaking around on the
beach but it didn't set up the tone of
the film right this boy was luca of
course his fear of going up to the
surface was slower and more calculated
in the movie
healthy
first time
of course it is
number eight this one's kind of a super
cool idea but not so great in practice
portoroso used to be a town filled with
sea monsters and it was half on land and
half underwater the choice to divide the
sea monster world and the human world
created much stronger stakes in the plot
making it taboo for the sea monsters to
go up to land made for much more
isolation in luka's journey and also
made it way more dangerous
you are monsters stop they're not
monster number nine imagine your first
introduction to the world being a
carnival our beloved duo of luca and
alberto was at first luca alberto and
the third wheel kid named chicho chicho
was cut from the gang but not all was
lost because he became one of hercules
goons it's good to recycle and that's
not all the three boys were met with a
carnival when they arrived in town for
the first time there was treasure water
balloon fights an awkward high five when
the concept of money went over our
hero's heads gelato bought by julia hot
chocolate dancing a parody on the lady
in the [ __ ] spaghetti scene first
photos a creepy puppet show with a
kraken oh and massimo still had both
arms and he had an obsession with sea
monsters or rather
see folk
what do you people know about sea
monsters
why would we know anything about sea
monsters number 10. here comes julia
there goes the dramatic tension an
alternate introduction for julia had her
discovering luca and alberto's secret
very early into the movie she meets the
boys at the tower and they hop in a boat
with her at one point they leap out of
the boat and julia jumps into the water
to help them but almost ends up drowning
herself the boys help her back into the
boat and she discovers their secret oh
wow
number 11 you're gonna be in gelato
trouble after this one luca this scene
about a gelato fight was an homage to
spaghetti western duels we can't help
but find it ironic they missed the
chance to go for a very on the nose
spaghetti pun by setting it at a gelato
shop instead unacceptable what's wrong
with you stupido number 12 who on earth
or under the sea thought a creepy dream
sequence is what this movie needed
luca has a dream that starts off fun in
a factory full of vespas and gelato that
ends at a pretty disturbing sea monster
cannery we can see why this one got cut
first off it's just yikes second off
there are much easier ways of addressing
those fears than with a super weird
dream sequence
i warned you about scorpios luca
number 13. dragon hearts don't exist in
flowers nice try though wow
the spirit
of sisu
we genuinely see why this whole glowing
flower plot was cut it's just fluff and
kind of reminds us of tangled to be
honest it's just a bunch of heart of the
dragon flowers growing in response to
one that's bloomed in response to being
given water one light can light a
thousand more
the metaphor is just a bit too on the
nose that's what the dragons did
they inspired light and hope in all the
people around them
number 14. what time do you eat dinner
sisu is hidden in two or maybe three
human disguises at the same time we
think that's how this feels oops heads
up the guy on the left looks twitchy
raya seemingly out of nowhere shouts
dinner time and
what it's like three o'clock in the
afternoon yeah that's even too early for
grandma's boom here comes tuk tuk there
are the baddies we need to get as much
distance as we can be number 15. if
grappling hooking wasn't a verb before
it is now while two men get into a food
fight on a bridge about moving their
wagon out of the way a monster rises
from the underground does this sound
like the start of a joke nope just an
early draft of the drones raya and
tuktuk come to the rescue raya gets
tossed from the bridge but grappling
hooks her way back to safety
number 16. if your team consists of
small children expect butt jokes boone
had an alternate introduction in the
movie and it started off kind of super
creepy with a droon hand caught and took
took's shell hugh boone to fix the plate
and tuk-tuk and also to make a butt joke
it's my pill bear here he's got a crack
who doesn't
which then turns into a mechanic under a
car situation yeah the whole thing is
just a bit off in this version by the
sounds of it namari is more than raya's
foil she's straight up an irredeemable
villain i'm teaming up with dragonblade
to take down omari and the druid
dragonblade number 17 imagine being the
world's most boring sidekick the early
draft of the drones sure are a heck of a
lot creepier huh they might have taken
disney out of the pg rating if they'd
remained there's also a dude who
attempts to be raya's sidekick he got
cut from the final film i'm sorry i have
to do this alone we're with raya on this
one he seems like a doll character i
don't need a sidekick number 18
we're just here for the unicorns well
you do only have like two memories of
them there's a very precious cut scene
in onward where a young ian is obsessed
with magic magic magic make the unicorns
fly however ian having no interest in
magic made the dynamic of the brothers
so much more vibrant this is probably
the most heartbreaking scene to be cut
because it's just so captivating seeing
the boys learn about their dad
our dad was a wizard
the last one in the whole world
the other thing that makes it
heartbreaking is we lost so many top
drawer unicorn jokes they can't fly the
wings don't work but this plotline of
the brothers both being excited about
magic led to other types of fun gags
like barley traversing swamps and
falling from trees to gather materials
for ian to do magic
and finally the unicorns have their day
the boys were making the world better
with magic your dad believed magic
brought out the best in everyone number
19. please tell us the dragon burger
isn't actually made of dragon there's a
chaotic scene set at ian's work dragon
burger there's a line of customers out
the door and then barley busts in to see
his brother and so do a bunch of
unicorns that's it we're protesting the
unicorns were the best part of this
whole movie but we can see why
everything else in this scene was cute
okay all right i'm calling angry number
20. it's funny how patterns present
themselves jenny the teenage seder was a
waiter in a restaurant who was going to
join the family trio on their adventure
hello sir nice to meet you my name is
jenny and before barley had guinevere
jenny had the car version of her you
sure this was a good idea nope that's
why jenny was cut are there any cut
scenes you think would have made the
movie better let us know in the comments
and thanks for hanging out with us here
at the things
[Music]